[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
you've probably seen a dolly camera move
something like that or maybe you've seen
a sort of a slow pan and arcing shot
these are all pretty common what about
something more complicated
[Music]
for that you're gonna need something a
little more dope
[Music]
what's up guys mkbhd here and welcome
back to dope tech for this one we flew
out to portland oregon home of motorized
precision to take a look at some robots
but not just any robots these are what i
would call cinema robots and as someone
that's into video at all
this is absolutely dope tech so like i
explained in the intro there are all
types of stabilizers and video tools and
things like that to help a human
move a camera in a certain way and
actually in most shots you can kind of
tell what type of device is being used
like this shot dolly cam this would be a
steadicam this is clearly a slider and
this is a crane but you've probably seen
some crazy shots in a movie or in a
music video somewhere for a shot like
this
the answer is kira kira has been
responsible for tons of shots in
commercials for tech products and car
videos etc and you might not even notice
but those are the shots that aren't cgi
but that are super precise and difficult
that a human could never do with any
tools that exist now hence the name
motorized precision and then the level
of dope tech is actually twofold here
it's the hardware with the actual robots
and mp studio the software to control
what these robots do and they can do
a lot here's the rundown so the kira
robot itself is fully metal extends up
to nine feet tall has a couple fully
articulating axes and it can move up to
nine feet per second in any direction
while carrying up to 40 pounds and then
the robot is controlled with an xbox
controller which has enough buttons to
hit every axis so you get forward
and backward
you get up
and down
pan left
and pan right
tilt up and tilt down and even roll
clockwise or roll counterclockwise and
once you've set the position you can
move the robot through space and time to
other positions with keyframes in the
software mp studio and on top of that if
you're using a manual lens which you
probably are at this point there's
motorized gears which are also part of
the robot which can control focus
iris and zoom during the camera move and
on top of all of that if you're shooting
with a red camera which is also
connected to the robot not only do you
get a live preview of what you're
pointed at and you have a remote start
stop but you also get all your red rock
controls so you can change resolution
shutter speed compression ratio white
balance etc
then you hit record it starts rolling on
the camera and you run the kira and it
plays through the move you made at the
speed you picked and then like i said it
can go really slow and smooth or it can
go fast it might be hard to appreciate
just how fast three meters per second
really is
but it's really fast you gotta you gotta
know exactly what you're doing to keep
it safe and then of course the other
upside of knowing exactly what you're
doing is all the shots you can get with
it the moves you can make are almost
literally endless so shout out to sean
brown the ceo of motorized precision for
showing me all this showing me the ropes
of the software and giving some examples
of what the robot can do so really the
only thing left to do now is
actually shoot with it so that's what we
did
first up the orbit shot
so this is fun this is just a bunch of
key frames highlighting different parts
from different angles of the same
subject and at every point the camera
stops and we made sure that keyframe
also had the subject perfectly in focus
and the end result just looks ridiculous
like you could see almost kind of like
this cgi the motion blur is just
dependent on the shutter speed we picked
but it's super real and then from behind
the scenes you can see all the hinges
working all the cables plugged into the
camera straight into the robot that's
talking to the computer
pretty incredible if you ask me
next up we did a bit more of a
traditional like a phone on a table shot
which you've seen before but with a
twist check this one out
[Music]
oh yeah okay so this one started off
slow like a normal slider shot like
you've seen before but then moved in
quick and focused on the camera of the
phone you can probably imagine doing
something like this with some motion
graphics or some tracked pointers in
there and again that shows off the
precision of the robot being able to
nail the focus instantly and you can't
forget the shot is also repeatable as
many times as you want so you can do it
multiple times with different phones
different items stack the clips mess
with opacity etc it's crazy but for me
the beauty of it is how close to the
table the whole rig gets without
touching it and there's no worries
because there's no shake or wobble at
all super precise
[Music]
okay so this one was pretty simple but
still if you saw it in a video you might
have your mind blown but it's up to the
top
spinning around
and then down on the other side and i
even think having more time with it we'd
be able to make this all like one
continuous move so you'd float over the
top of the laptop spin around without
stopping and then come down on the other
side but nevertheless pretty sure that's
next to impossible without this robot
and then next we decided to do something
a little bit more difficult
[Music]
okay so that was sick but the challenge
here what really makes this one more
difficult is the fact that i'm a human
not a robot and it's actually really
hard for me to hold myself on the phone
in the exact same spot for long enough
that we can set up all the keyframes and
the robot can do the move and get the
phone in focus every time so there's
actually plenty of takes that we didn't
use that ended with the phone being like
a little bit out of focus because i had
moved but i think getting this one right
made it that much more impressive and
then last but not least we broke out a
bit of a different robot also made by
motorized precision this one's called
mia instead of kira it's a little bit
lighter a little bit smaller uh but
still equally impressive could probably
fit something like this in our studio
wink wink
but it's also now on a massive motorized
track system so we did a little walking
tracking shot
[Music]
so obviously that one's equally awesome
for the little bit of time we had to
play with it and set it up you know
matching my speed with the walking of
the robot sliding speed and then
stopping at just the right place so it
swings past my head instead of through
my head obviously absolutely worth it so
that's it that's the beauty of motorized
precision robots that control and hold
cameras that can pull off low speed or
high speed moves precisely that humans
literally can't obviously you can take
this thing to the next level if you've
got like a slow motion camera on there
like if you imagine a phantom flex on
this arm swinging around super fast the
shots you could get out of it are
absolutely incredible and again if you
can't underwrite the software mp studio
there are older iterations of this same
sort of robot control thing where you
literally have to put in coordinates
into an excel spreadsheet to get a robot
to move like this so obviously this is
miles better generally people don't buy
these robots they get rented for certain
shoots like the commercials and music
videos we talked about but uh let me
know what would you use a robot like
this for so either way that's been it uh
hey kira you mind if we do this outro
together
so we're just gonna wave goodbye ready
thanks for watching guys talk to you
next one peace
[Music]